thank you gentlemen that was my
monologue tonight I hope you all enjoyed
it thank you very much press secretary
and Richard good evening I'm Andy
Richter press secretary for mr. O'Brian
I'll be taking questions from select
members of the press but first let me
just say I hope you enjoyed what was
without a doubt the funniest monologue
ever told on television ok first
question you yeah I got mister when
Conan said you guys had a great show
tonight
did he really mean that uh no I think
what he meant to say was that we have an
incredibly great show
next question yeah mr. Richter this
studio holds an audience of around 200
yet mr. O'Brian recently claimed that
holds 20,000 we stand by our number of
20,000 period yeah but there clearly are
news mr. O'Brien says 20,000 largest
[Applause]
what about reports that Conan's jokes
are sometimes met with an uncomfortable
silence from the studio audience and
that's completely false anything that
sounds like silence we like to think of
that as an alternative laughs yes yes
you toning does Conan does something
called this string dance why does he
insist he has string coming out of his
hips when 99% of scientists say that is
false we have our own science okay our
data shows the string is there next
question please mr. rickter your jacket
isn't it a little big now it's perfectly
what do you say to the hundreds of
protesters outside angrily shouting
Conan's name those aren't protesters
actually those are Conan employees those
people have no rights yeah next question
yep sometimes in the monologue Conan
brags that he has a very big penis and
sometimes he jokes that he has a tiny
penis which is it well it's both Conan's
penis is ten inches long when urinating
and when aroused it's an angry tube of
chapstick could we can we go back to
your suit don't you see how baggy the
shoulder about the suit it fits fine no
more questions oh my god we got a great
show tonight ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
Scientology Leah Remini
[Applause]
12:03 coast of the Comedy Central series
Jeff Ross presents roast battle to war
of the words Jeff Ross is here
three gold medals three gold medals
hey the Queen of England elizabeth ii is
here tonight to make her american late
night television debut that's the ghost
of richard briers here musical guest
foxy gin is here TV take it away
[Applause]
you